i i i've heard this come up twice now
that voters are lazy and i want to
address this
why do you think
mark zuckerberg dumped 150 or whatever
how many hundreds of millions of dollars
into a get out the vote campaign pushing
everybody to vote go vote go vote go
vote go vote go vote because people
don't do their research they vote for
who they're told to vote for i don't
think they have a big opinion yeah i
think that's exactly why i i don't think
voters are lazy but i don't think
politics is the topic but but wait a
minute let's unpack that my friend tyler
here so
i think majority are lazy
but the minority is going to determine
the next president and if you got a
million people who flipped you don't
need everybody that's a million people
who flipped that's the truth a million
who flipped okay
is trump good at making allies what's
his resume show and him creating allies
who's who's fired more people on his own
administration than him i don't know a
lot of people okay so that tv show was
not a show
that's
that's him okay
so so if if he's gonna go
a person needs to get in there to give
that side of marketing storytelling
if he continues with this part about you
know it's not fair it's not fair it's
not fair he's got three to six months to
make changes i think three to six months
later it's going to be
who's going to be pushed i think in as
of right now i actually agree with the
way it is today i think this thing can
flip in six to twelve months and it can
flip very quickly in what regard flip it
oh flip meaning if he goes
people are not inspired by feel sorry
for me
people are not inspired by it's not fair
that's not an inspirational message
people are not inspired by an entitled
message
and his messaging is i deserve to be
there right now it's just listen it's
not attractive go fight and win it again
and
change
like now when people are struggling so
much with like inflation with like basic
basic needs they could both think that
he look that he won and it was unfair
and feel like why are you why is he not
feeling sorry for me why am i being
asked to expend pity on this person
who's a millionaire and i can't afford
to fill up my car with gas i think that
that's the that's really important this
is like the easiest time for him to just
say
i have nothing to say this is all thing
i will tell you a month before kovit
here was the economy before after and
say nothing else
just do that and show that the
powerpoint of every speech he would give
if i was his campaign manager the next
three six 12 months i'm gonna say the
following look
let's move on with what happened with
2016 20 uh 2020 election forget about it
let's move on with my conflicts with
pence let's move on with all that stuff
this is all i will tell you
this is me pre-covered what america was
like this is you today how do you feel
about it how are you being impacted by
it forget about if you don't like me
because i'm pompous and i'm loud and i'm
this i'm from new york this is my dna if
you've been in the real estate world and
you know how it is to compete this is
how you have to be to compete i've been
like this for 77 78 years it's what's
helped me get here this is how i got
here but forget about set aside your
emotions you don't like me okay for me
being allowed how do you feel about this
you know math you don't need to know
science to see this what do you like do
you like this or do you like this when i
was in what did you hear about isis what
did you hear about this what did you
hear about that what happened here our
administration did a better job with
this theirs is not you want this
continue if you don't
we're coming back and if you want this
if he took that approach a lot of the
people that would hate him they would go
like this
i like this guy but listen i'm i got to
give him credit yep
he's showing i got to give him credit
if he can't get out of his own way he's
screwed you got six months by the way
you only have six months
you only have six months to flip that so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]